hey guys Pete here Westworld season 1
episode 5 has dropped and we have a lot
to talk about this will be my episode 5
recap and review and will contain
spoilers for everything that's happened
in West world up to this point I'm
tweaking my West world episode videos
format again so this will be a brief
scene by scene with some thoughts about
the storylines at the end with all that
out of the way let's jump right into
this episode episode 5 starts out with
dr. Ford in the cold storage area
talking to the old host we saw in an
earlier episode he tells him a story
from childhood about the saddest thing
he ever saw it's a story about him and
his brother getting a dog an old gray
house it took the dog to the park and
let her off the leash and then it sees a
cat mistaking it for the felt rabbit he
had changed during his races he ran
after the cat caught it he killed the
cat and then sat there looking confused
Ford says the dog had spent his whole
life trying to catch that thing now it
had no idea what to do
it's a telling story and that it had
such an effect on him as a child
it isn't that Ford was terrorized about
the killing of the cat but that it was
sad for him to see that once the dog
caught the that thing
it was then lost we catch up with
Dolores he's hearing voices she hears
things like find me and then says show
me how at that moment when you realize
she isn't alone instead she's with
William Logan and slim who have just
arrived outside of pariah
Logan describes the place as a city of
outcasts
delinquents thieves [ __ ] and murderers
slim assures them that they will be
rewarded by Lazo and William asked to
Loras if she's alright after the others
start off he says he heard her talking
to someone and she says it must have
been the wind as they walk into the town
we can see that it's massive and there's
a lot going on
it looks more chaotic and bustling
compared to Sweetwater
and there's a definite feeling of
lawlessness Logan explains to William
that the further out you go the more
grandiose the narratives become he says
that that doesn't come cheap though and
rumors are that Westworld is
hemorrhaging cash the company is
thinking of buying them out he also
mentions that it started out as a
partnership but one of the partners
killed themselves just before the park
opened we learned that there's a
the men called Confederate O's in the
park who called themselves the army of
the new Virginia and that Logan is
basically out to get involved but their
narrative about going to war supposedly
this happens out at the end of the park
but Logan has never made it that far
dolorous mentions that her father told
her about the Confederate OHS soldiers
that refused to surrender after the war
who now work as mercenaries beyond
border the man in black is still
traveling with Lawrence and we see that
he has Teddy slumped over a horse riding
along with him Lawrence says that teddy
was Wyatt's friend and the man in black
confirms that that's why they brought
him along he expects Teddy will lead him
right to Wyatt as he talked about his
dire situation the small boy we saw Ford
talking with and sees in Episode two
shows up the man in black sends him to
get water right after Lawrence says that
Teddy won't make it after losing so much
blood we learned that the plan is to
drain Lawrence's blood and give it to
Teddy as he slits his throat and hangs
him up to let it drain we see Mavis
being repaired and learned that one of
the texts is a real douchebag the other
tack whose name we learn is Felix later
in the show it still freaked out from
enough time when she got up from the
table and took off as they're working he
notices that she had a knife wound and
that it looked like they were digging
around for something of course this was
from the last scene of the last episode
when they found the bullet they had left
behind they take their lunch break and
we see that there's something in the
cabinet where the second tack leaves his
computer Tony looks a little better
after he gets some of Lawrence's blood
but there he's still in bad shape at
first he asks the man in black to kill
him out of mercy and then the man in
black tricks him into coming along by
lying that Wyatt had taken Dolores
he knows this will work to get Teddy
involved and sure enough Teddy stands
and walks to the horses the man in black
tells the boy not to worry about
Lawrence that someone will be alone for
him shortly Lord's are still having
visions of the scene around the white
church William asked if she's all right
and they start to talk about changing
your life he mentions maybe that's why
people come here because they can change
the story
be whatever they want and that people in
the real world don't even know about it
she asked what he means by the real
world
and he deflects by saying that he
thought they weren't supposed to notice
things like that she tells him recently
she feels like the whole world is
calling to her in a way it never has
before he touches her hand and then a
parade starts to come down the street
Logan comes back and slim tells them
that a Lhasa has agreed to give them an
audience the very next day he says there
is a brothel they should check out in
the meantime and the two of them have
words about Dolores
William says not to refer to her as a
doll because he thinks there's something
going on with her and she sort of
understands Logan says of course you
would think that again we get reminded
of how over the top pariah is as Dolores
moves into the parade as she's looking
for something as she's walking me here
dr. Ford's voice say something to the
effect of rest and dream slow and she
passes it passes out right there when
she wakes up she's in the programming
Center with Ford across from her to go
through the normal routine where do you
know where you are and she says I'm in a
dream and this time he adds the esta
Loras you're in my dream talk about
dreams and he asked her if she's been
thinking of getting out of her modest
slew taking on a bigger role he talks
about his father telling him to learn to
accept his lot in life because the world
didn't know him anything and how he just
decided to build his own world he asked
if she remembered the man he used to be
when she says she doesn't he says but
you must remember him the man who
created you he's referring to Arnold and
when she continues to say she doesn't
remember he tells her that under all
those updates that he is still inside
her her mind is a walled garden that not
even death can stop the flowers from
growing there he asked her if she's been
hearing voices has Arnold been talking
to her and when she doesn't say anything
he puts her in analysis mode he asked
when her last contact with Arnold was
and she responds 34 years 42 days seven
hours ago this was the day Arnold died
and when he asked she says the last
thing he told her was that she was going
to help him destroy this place and the
Andy says he's sorry for bothering her
but that she's the only one still left
that was around back then no one else
knows like they know he switches her off
and leaves the room but we hear her say
he doesn't know
I didn't tell him anything we see that
the tech that has a bird hidden in the
cabinet that he's working on he gets it
to come back online right as the other
tech comes into the room but it's more
flailing around and flying he has the
other guy grab it it bites him and they
start arguing the douchey guy tells him
that he isn't an ornithologist or a
coder so he better just destroy the bird
before he gets in trouble for
misappropriating corporate property then
he tells them that they have another
body and we see it's Maeve again when he
says it's her again the second text said
that he should have been weeded out in
the personality testing process before
they ever hired him for the job
William is still concerned with Delores
and when he asked how she's doing she
says she's been having troubled dreams
she says she feels more like herself now
and Logan interrupts to say Allah so
waits when they approach the man sitting
at his table we realized that Allah so
is actually Lawrence Logan tells him
that in recompense for saving slim they
want to be introduced to the campus
Confederate o friends he tells him no
and when Logan tries to push the issue
Lawrence's man punches Logan in the face
this sends Dolores into a vision and
then she tells Allah so that she knows
he's looking for something if he lets
them she knows they can help after this
he offers him a job stealing a
nitroglycerin shipment from a Union
convoy Logan excitedly accepts but
William points out that the Confederate
owes want the explosive to use against
Lawrence people in their raids he
assures him that personal grudges have
no place where profit is concerned the
Lord gets a new outfit and we can see
that she's now packing heat she has
concerns about harming the soldiers in
the robbery and what ensures her that no
one will get hurt
as they're getting the nitro with no
problems Logan decides to try and teach
the driver a lesson he pulls him down
starts beating him up but in the process
the soldier is able to tackle him this
gets slim killed and eventually William
has to start killing the soldiers to
save Dolores after one of them picks up
the gun that slim dropped of course
Logan thinks this is all great but
Dolores is upset that they lied to the
men
ended up killing them they load up Sims
body and head back to pariah Alonso
takes the shipment and sells it to the
Confederate OHS they're eager to go and
start blowing things up but he convinces
them to stay for one more night of
partying at the brothel they agree and
the leader walks off with his arm around
Logan telling him who will be a great
asset to their ranks Ellie's working on
a host when she sees the stray being
pushed by on a car she asked where
they're taking it and the two tech say
they're taking it to livestock and then
to the incinerator she decides to follow
and we see that her being there freaks
out the other texts that had the bird we
see her go into the room next door and
shake down the tech in there for having
sex with the host in the center when she
was in for repair Ella uses this to get
access to the stray to check him out
after looking him over she discovers
there's something hidden under her skin
she starts to remove it and we don't
find out exactly what it is until later
when she's talking to Bernard she takes
it to him and says that someone has been
using this satellite uplink to smuggle
dad out of the park at the brothel we
see that it is absolutely over the top
and they that the only one who's really
enjoying it is Logan the Confederate Oh
leader says they should join him in the
war and William once again objects this
time Logan pushes him to the point of
William actually getting up and sort of
grabbing up pushing against the wall he
was belittling him about work-related
things and he said he's picked him
because he was no threat to anyone while
they're arguing Dolores wanders off and
ends up in a room with the fortune
teller she fans out her cards and when
Dolores picks one it has the maze
printed on it when she asked what it
means the fortune teller turns into her
and she tells herself she must follow
the maze
she asked what's wrong with her and the
other says maybe you're unraveling at
this point she sees a little something
poking out of a wrist and it starts
tearing out her skin when she pulls on
it it's only a vision but when she looks
back at her wrist to see it's okay she
ends up running out of the room because
the other version of herself disappears
and you know she's generally freaked out
she ends up going down a flight of
stairs where she sees that Lawrence is
planning on betraying the Confederate
owes he's pumping all the nitroglycerine
into slims body and refilling the
empty bottles with tequila she knows
this is gonna be a big problem so she
runs upstairs to warn William that they
should get out of there fast William
says he knows that they're being forced
to take action by the park but he's not
gonna play along with it she stresses to
him that it isn't a game and that she
knows that together they can find a way
out she says there's a voice inside her
telling her what to do and that it's
telling her that she needs him then she
kisses him outside some of the
Confederate OHS are throwing the bottles
of what they think are nitro back and
forth one eventually falls on the ground
and breaks and when it doesn't explode
the leader knows he's been this betrayed
his men start beating up Logan as
William decides to leave with Dolores
she says they have Logan but William
decides to leave him there the
Confederate o leader cuts them off and
Dolores ends up killing everyone nearby
when William asked how she was able to
do it she says that people come here to
change their lives the story of their
lives
she just imagined a story where she
didn't have to be the damsel they hear a
train whistle in the background and take
off to try to catch it they make it just
in time and when they go inside they
find the Lazo with Slim's body in the
final car they settle in for what he
says will be a long ride to the front
and the scene ends with the look when
Dolores notices that the maze is printed
on the top of Slim's casket Teddy and
the man in black enter a saloon we
haven't seen before and they ordered
whiskey when it comes it's delivered by
dr. Ford himself the two of them have
been back and forth about what the man
in black is looking for and Ford says
that he doesn't have the imagination to
conceive of someone like him men in
black asked if Wyatt was made as a
worthy adversary for him someone to stop
him from making it to the center of the
maze Ford asks what he's hoping to find
there
he tells Teddy a story about why people
come there and then says he's thinking
there is something deeper something the
man who created it wanted to express
something true Ford says he can just ask
if he's looking for the moral of the
story but the man in black says he would
need a shovel since the man he needs to
talk to you died 35 years ago he then
says maybe he left something behind and
then pulls out his knife while saying I
wonder
I find if I opened you up Teddy grabs a
knife by the blade to protect Ford and
the man in black asks if Ford came to
talk him into stopping this quest for
says by no means he has no interest in
stopping someone on a journey of
self-discovery then gets up and leaves
when he when he does the room comes back
to life
Teddy slams his drink and then gets up
saying they need to get back on the road
that they're losing time in the final
scene we see that Maeve is back
underground and that the tech is working
on the bird again as he works on the
code we see the bird spring to life and
start flying around the room as he's
watching it aesthetically the bird flies
over and lands on mates hand and we see
that she is sitting up and conscious she
says hello Felix it's time you and I had
a chat in the episode and so a ton of
surprising things happen in this episode
by the end I was wondering how this
group of characters will continue past
this season it just has a feeling that
either Ford or the man in black or both
are going to reach a conclusion in their
storylines in the next five episodes I
don't know though I guess anything could
happen at the end of every Dexter season
it was hard to figure out how they'd
have another one but these are big
characters who would be hard to contract
for a five season run and their stories
are heading towards something fast
we got nearly no barnard in know Teresa
at all on this episode the satellite
uplink device is an interesting twist
but not much to go on as to who might
have put it there
Dolores his only interaction was with
Ford who pulled her out intentionally we
see that she's still struggling with the
changes she's going through but she's
making the right decisions that are
leading her towards the maze obviously
this will be exactly what the man in
black needs to get there himself the
foreshadowing of dr. Ford's Greyhound
story is something to tuck away in the
back of our minds it's about getting
that thing you've always wanted
but being left with no sense of purpose
afterwards we could speculate about this
in the comments but this scene in story
seemed important we discovered what
Logan's financial motivations were this
isn't terribly surprising but the
tension that's building between him and
Willy
will certainly lead to something I found
the pariah narrative to be really crazy
but was left wondering why or how it's
been changed so that the maze keeps
being shown to Dolores we know the man
in black it has made it through this
narrative in the past with his long
association with Lawrence so was he
introduced to the maze but just couldn't
find it before I'm a little confused on
this and not sure how it would relate to
the Wyatt story or the scenes with the
wait church that Dolores keeps
envisioning I'm excited to see how they
all tie together though the man in black
continues to get more interesting as and
as we learn more about how the hosts and
narratives work his mastery becomes more
clear it seems like every decision he
makes as a function of playing a game
with the desired outcome based on his
experience so you could say you know
he's leveled up compared to all the
other guests I feel like with each
episode a lot of the early theories like
the alternate timeline theory get more
holes in them and don't really hold up
and the characters seem to turn out to
be what they are presented as at the
same time the writers definitely toss
things add us to make us doubt the
reality though I mean in this episode
the man in black threatens to cut open
four which is a clear implication that
he might just be a host that Arnold
created but I think Ford is most likely
human and this is just a red herring to
make us think in the first episode we
saw that Dolores was capable of
deception in this episode we see that
she can even to see doctor for this
makes for some very interesting
possibilities in the future hopefully it
will get more barnard in Dolores
one-on-ones in the next episode to help
sort out the details that's it for this
week's episode the trailer looks
absolutely insane and I guess it should
since we're halfway through the season
at this point there were so many good
points and scenes in this episode but if
I had to pick one I think Maeve having
the bird land on her finger was the top
moment let me know in the comments what
your favorite scene was and where you
think things are headed please like the
video if you liked it and subscribe to
my channel to find out about all my new
videos as soon as they come out thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon